[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
guten abend hinein follow that money ist
eine alte journalistin regel um den
dingen wirklich auf den grund zu gehen
die spur des geldes für zu interessanten
überraschenden verstörenden einblick
nehmen der saudi arabien das land
importiert gerade im großen stil öl aus
russland
ja sie haben richtig gehört der
weltgrößte ölexporteur kauft selbst
kräftig ein bei wladimir putin das
russische öl ist für den saudischen
binnen verbrauch und erlaubt dem land so
sein eigenes öl zu rekordpreisen auf dem
weltmarkt loszuschlagen so legen dass
zumindest die exportdaten nach dem
us-präsidenten geht das gehörig gegen
den strich er muss dringend etwas
unternehmen gegen hohe ölpreise die die
eigenen wähler aufbringen nur hat er
gerade in den golfstaaten keine
besonders gute verhandlungsposition
brigitte sa berichtet
dass der golf kooperationsrat gerade in
dieser tag ist ein guter anlass für
diese mission doch die gespräche laufen
nicht gerade überschwänglich allenfalls
höflich das treffen mit dem saudischen
kronprinzen ist heikel hatte beiden dem
gastgeber doch damit gedroht ihn wegen
des mordes an kassen zu lassen jetzt
will der us-präsident wieder mehr
zusammenarbeit mit saudi arabien und in
anderen ländern
die usa wollen eine positive zukunft für
den nahen osten wir wollen ihr partner
sein wir werden uns nicht zurückziehen
und ein vakuum hinterlassen
das dann gefüllt wird von china russland
oder dem iran amerika wird durch auf
prinzipien basierende führung
mitgestalten
am dringlichsten aber braucht beiden
zunächst mal mehr öl von saudi arabien
im kampf gegen die energiekrise und die
inflation bislang hat der kronprinz aber
lediglich gesagt dass er bereit ist die
förderkapazitäten zu erhöhen
es gab keine verbindliche zusage der
golfstaaten dass sie tatsächlich mehr
energie in den internationalen markt
oder an die usa stattdessen haben sie
auf die nächste sitzung der opec plus
länder verwiesen
auch der vorstoß eine neue allianz gegen
den iran zu schmieden wurde in jeddah
teils nur verhalten aufgenommen und so
gibt es wenig konkrete ergebnisse mit
denen der amerikanische präsident nun
zurück nach washington fliegt
ja man muss also jedes wort ganz genau
lesen saudi arabien deutet jetzt also an
seine mögliche
förderkapazität zu erhöhen elmar
theveßen in saudi arabien ist denn das
für beiden erfolg genug um die
weltweiten spritpreise dämpfen zu können
also das reicht natürlich nicht obwohl
vielleicht in den nächsten tagen wegen
der freudigen erwartung dann die
ölpreise doch ein bisschen sinken werden
aber joe biden muss warten bis die opec
entscheidet er scheint er aber sehr sehr
zuversichtlich zu sein es geht ja bei
diesem gipfel immer um die so genannten
dinge wolbergs also was nimmt man mit
nach hause was liefert man zu hause ab
und da denken dann manche da müsste der
präsident doch eigentlich jetzt eine
million barrel öl in seinem flugzeug air
force one mit nach hause bringen oder
vielleicht sogar noch einen
arabisch-israelischen friedensvertrag
obendrauf aber das weiße haus misst das
alles mit einem anderen maßstab und das
konnte man in den letzten monaten bei
den reisen von joe biden sehen da ging
es natürlich einerseits um eigene
wirtschaftsinteressen aber eben auch ums
große ganze nämlich den antagonismus
gegen russland und gegen china er war in
der indie- pazifischen region unterwegs
beim g 7 in deutschland beim nato gipfel
in madrid jetzt hier und da ging es eben
darum zu zeigen man ist wieder
verlässlicher partner und bietet auch
was an was ganz konkretes vielen
beispiel von hier nennen da hat man sich
darauf verständigt dass die usa helfen
werden die 5d und 6b mobilfunk netze
auszubauen ein auftrag den die chinesen
auch sehr gern bekommen hätten jetzt
wahrscheinlich eher die usa und darum
geht es im grunde genommen zu zeigen
dass diese länder interessen haben eher
mit demokratien zusammen zu arbeiten als
mit den autoritären regimen wie russland
und china ob die rechnung am ende
aufgeht das entscheidet sich sicherlich
nicht an einer million barrel öl sondern
das ist ein längerer prozess und wieder
ausgeht das werden wir erst in den
nächsten monat wahrscheinlich erfahren
die analyse live aus saudi arabien dma
herzlichen dank
wir erleben in diesem sommer einen blick
in unsere klimazukunft viele experten
sind angesichts der aktuellen
nachrichten daher auch er alarmiert als
überrascht für fast ganz spanien und
portugal gilt eine hitzewarnung der
wetterdienste in vielen regionen mehr
als 40 grad manchmal bis zu 44 grad dazu
extreme trockenheit die behörden melden
bereits hunderte hitzetod und die
feuerwehren kämpfen gegen dutzende
waldbrände kameras auf jahre mit dem
überblick
sie machen gerade campingurlaub in
beliebten italienischen badeort bibione
als eine feuerwalze sie überrascht die
urlauber hätten sich in ihrer not ins
wasser die küstenwache kann sich später
retten hitze und trockenheit haben das
urlaubsparadies sekundenschnell in ein
inferno verwandelt auch an der
spanischen costa del sol werden urlauber
beim baden von einer riesigen rauchwolke
überrascht spanien hat derzeit mit über
30 waldbränden zu kämpfen angefacht
durch temperaturen von über 40 grad
tausende müssen bei malaga wegen
nahender flammen in sicherheit gebracht
werden
alles was ich habe ist mein haus ich
konnte gerade noch meine katze und
meinen hund retten das war alles ich
hoffe sie können mein haus retten
spanien ächzt unter einer rekordhitze in
der hauptstadt madrid suchen die
menschen nur irgendwie abkühlung die
hitzewelle hat in spanien bisher
mindestens 360 tote gefordert
auch portugal beklagt über 200 hitze
tote temperaturen von über 40 grad die
menschen in lissabon suchen schattige
plätze auf
östliche von porto müssen sie hilflos
zusehen wie sich das feuer durch den
wald trend löschflugzeuge müssen
gefährliche manöver fliegen um die
brände zu löschen
ein pilot stürzt heute im bergigen
gelände ab die schäden in portugal sind
enorm landesweit hat das feuer in einer
woche schon mehr als 25.000 hektar land
zerstört das entspricht rund 35.000
fußballfeldern bis sonntag gilt hier der
notstand
klar habe ich angst aber wohin soll ich
gehen in einem wassertank springen
lassen sie mich hier bleiben und
abwarten ich werde sicher nicht ins bett
gehen
auch an der französischen atlantikküste
brennt es löschflugzeuge sind im
dauereinsatz
die rettungskräfte müssen rund 12.000
menschen in sicherheit bringen viele
helfer sind am rande der erschöpfung
denn das feuer frisst sich immer weiter
südeuropa im sommer 2022
auch der britische wetterdienst warnt
vor extremer hitze für weite teile
englands am kommenden montag und
dienstag
es ist das erste mal überhaupt dass
großbritannien so eine warnung bekommt
weitere wichtige nachrichten jetzt von
heute die heinz zugrunde lagen im osten
der ukraine zeichnet sich eine
verstärkung der russischen aggression ab
verteidigungsminister schoigu hat eine
ausweitung der angriffe befohlen durch
russische raketen wurden in mikro drei
menschen getötet 15 verletzt
widerspricht russland von einem
militärischen ziel überprüfen lässt sich
das nicht
trotz der energiekrise in folge des
krieges will bundeskanzler scholz alles
tun um den klimawandel zu bekämpfen und
setzt dabei auf den ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien in seiner
wöchentlichen videobotschaft sagte er es
sei bitter dass wegen des brutalen
angriffs russlands kraftwerke genutzt
werden müssten die eigentlich schon
außer betrieb seien
überfällig der rücktritt von documenta
chefin schormann so die reaktion des
antisemitismus beauftragten der
bundesregierung
einvernehmlich wurde der vertrag
aufgelöst
konsequenz aus dem eklat bei der welt
kunstschau in kassel das werk
indonesischer künstler das
judenfeindliche motive zeigte wurde
zunächst verhüllt und drei tage nach
ausstellungsbeginn abgebaut
jetzt ist es offiziell
weltfußballer robert lewandowski
verlässt bayern münchen und wechselt zum
fc barcelona ablösesumme 45 millionen
euro plus 5 millionen an bonuszahlungen
einen dreijahresvertrag soll der star
erhalten und die bayern müssen ohne den
33-jährigen auskommen
die gewinnzahlen von motto ohne gewähr
15 17 20 22 23 26 superzahl 8 mehr auf
lotto zdf de und im zdf text die
hitzewelle kommt auch nach deutschland
ab montagmorgen sind es noch 19 bis 25
grad im norden und osten zahlreiche
wolken es bleibt trocken sonst viel
sonne von meist wolkenlosem himmel bis
32 grad dann kommt die hitze höhepunkt
am dienstag im westen werte bis 40 grad
am mittwoch bringen dort gewitter eine
kleine abkühlung
wir kommen wieder morgen dann
ausführlich für heute danke für das
interesse und viel spaß beim spielen am
tisch
[Musik]